[Music]
breaking news this Monday night
international murder For Hire
accusations Iran recruited two Canadians
to carry out assassinations in the US
this politicization of Hitman is really
terrifying what we know about the
suspects and the targets avenging the
killing of three American soldiers we
are not looking for a war with Iran how
Washington will
respond not ready why a decision to
expand assisted death to those with
mental illness has been delayed and new
examples of meddling in Canada the
revelations as the foreign interference
inquiry gets
underway global national with Donna
freen good evening and thanks for
joining us we begin with a murder For
Hire plot revealed by the US justice
department that involves charges against
two Canadian men accused of plotting to
kill an Iranian Defector living in the
US the US indictment unsealed today
names two men one a member of the Hell's
Angels in BC it alleges they conspired
with an Iranian man through an encrypted
messaging service to recruit Hitmen to
travel to the US and carry out the
killing of two people in Maryland the US
justice department says it's a part of a
troubling trend of transnational
repression in which operatives from
countries including Iran and China
Target dissidents and defectors on
foreign soil Eric Sorenson has our top
story
tonight the US justice department calls
it an international murder For Hire
scheme an assassination plot by Iranian
intelligence to kill a Defector and
woman living in Maryland near Washington
and hired two Canadian men to carry it
out Naji sharifi zashi is accused of
running a criminal Network targeting
dissidents at the behest of Iran's
Ministry of intelligence and security to
silence the Iranian regime's perceived
critics us officials alleged zind dasi
recruited Damian patri R Ryan a member
of the Hell's Angels in BC and that Ryan
recruited Adam Richard Pearson another
Hell's Angels member to carry out the
attack according to the indictment
Pearson promised to recruit others
texting Ryan that he would encourage the
recruits to shoot the victim in the head
a lot to make example that he would tell
them we got to erase the head from the
Torso Kim Bolan has investigated many
cases involving Canadian gang members to
see sort of the involvement of even L
level Canadian gangsters BC gangsters is
really frightening we know there's been
a lot of violence uh amongst gangs in
the drug trade but sort of this
politicization of Hitman is really
terrifying us authorities says zashi and
the Canadians used an encrypted
messaging service to orchestrate the
plot that began in late 2020 in early
2021 zashi was prepared to pay
$350,000 us for us authorities it's a
case that predates recent middle
tensions showing Iran's efforts to
repress dissident and critics both
inside and outside the country this
analyst says it is a wakeup call for
Canadian authorities reality is now set
in that we've lost such control of our
impact on transnational organized crime
that we're so far behind that these
individuals are almost operating with
impunity the justice department says the
FBI is investigating the case with
valuable assistance from the RCMP and
CIS the Canadian Security and
intelligence service both Canadians are
already in custody in Canada on
unrelated charges Ryan on Firearms
charges and Pearson was arrested in the
US 3 years ago and extradited to Canada
in an Alberta murder case Eric senson
Global News
Toronto the US has now identified the
three American Army Reserve soldiers
killed in a drone attack on a US
military Outpost in Jordan at least 30
others were injured in that attack which
happened while many service members were
sleeping American officials accuse Iran
of having its fingerprints on the attack
and President Joe Biden has vowed to
retaliate the question is when and how
Jackson prco is watching this in
Washington tonight
Jackson hi Donna what happens next is an
open question after the US military
suffered its worst loss of life in one
incident since the fall of Afghanistan
the attack happened at an outpost known
as Tower 22 in Jordan near the border
with Syria the US says the base supports
us Special Operations against the
so-called Islamic State initial reports
suggest air defenses may have missed the
unmanned attack drone because it struck
at the same time an American drone was
returning to base tonight the US is
blaming Iranian backed militia groups
while saying Iran has its fingerprints
on the attack US President Joe Biden is
receiving regular briefings and is said
to be weighing his options the wh house
says a response will come at a time and
in a manner of Biden's choosing we are
not looking for a war with with Iran
they are not seeking a conflict with the
regime in a military way um and as I
said in in the opening we're not we're
not looking to escalate here this attack
over the weekend was escalatory make no
mistake about it and it requires a
response make no mistake about that
neither the White House nor the Pentagon
would discuss potential options for
retaliation it's a difficult balancing
act because the US is unequivocal that
Iran Bears some degree of responsibility
the Americans are looking to deter
future attacks and send a message to
Tyron without provoking a full-on war
there have been at least 160 attacks on
US troops in the region since October
7th some causing serious injuries to
American troops but this is the first
one to cause fatalities Donna okay
Jackson prco in Washington thanks how to
handle foreign countries and agents who
interfere in domestic affairs is a
growing question for democracies
everywhere including Canada the
long-awaited public inquiry into foreign
interference got underway in Ottawa
today it's looking into how countries
like China Russia Iran and India may
have interfered in Canadian Democratic
processes and as David Aken reports
Global News has just learned of a new
case of possible Chinese interference
David well Donna one of the reasons the
government convened this inquiry is
because of reporting Global News did and
continues to do about foreign
interference in Canadian political
affairs case in point Global News has
learned that the federal government
ordered a Chinese woman deported last
August after immigration officials
concluded she was working for the
government of communist China to try to
silence criticism and dissent by members
of the Chinese diaspora here in Canada
the immigration and Refugee board ruled
that the woman had worked for the
overseas Chinese Affairs office and that
that organization quote was and remains
involved in Espionage against prc's
targeted individual ual and groups in
Canada for privacy reasons Federal
authorities cannot say if the
deportation order has been carried out
the judge overseeing the public inquiry
into foreign interference acknowledged
the role Global News and others have had
in putting foreign interference on the
public agenda given the importance of
protecting our democracy these
allegations have sparked significant
debate and discussion both at the
political level and in in the media
Global News and other news organizations
have legal standing at this inquiry we
will be here to uh make sure and defend
the right of the public to information
that could be a challenge consider this
just a half a percent of all the
exhibits Ted at the emergencies act
inquiry were classified top secret
0.5% for this foreign interference
inquiry 80% of all exhibits are top
secret or hire transparency is necessary
to ensure Canadians have confidence in
their in their elections Canadians have
the right to know what happened how
their government responded and the
ongoing threats that may persist and so
that is the commission's first key task
sorting out the rules around handling
top secret information it's a task that
could take most of the week Donna all
right David Aken in Ottawa thank you the
federal government says the country is
not ready to expand eligibility for
medical assisted death to people whose
sole medical condition is a mental
illness the system needs to be ready and
we need to get it right and it's clear
from the conversations we have that the
system is at this time not ready and
therefore need more time Health Minister
Mark Holland said it is not a matter of
if but when those suffering from severe
mental illness will have access to
medically assisted death the expansion
was set to take place on March 17th new
legislation will now be drafted in the
coming days to push that deadline back
further also on the agenda today is
Parliament resumed the cost of living
and housing the right honorable prime
minister the government is under
increasing pressure to address Canada's
housing Crunch and affordability it
already announced a temporary cap on
international student visas and today
the government said it will offer
lowcost loans to builders and
post-secondary schools to encourage the
construction of student housing
Mackenzie gray looks at how the measures
are intended to work Mr trador you
after a 6 week break parliamentarians
picked up where they left off oral
questions bickering over just about
everything why does this government wait
until things are at a breaking point
before acting will at least allow
Canadians to heat their homes without
his tax is abolishing the United Nations
now the official position of the
Conservative Party of
Canada but outside the House of Commons
a more civil tone this is going to be a
major change in approach in a few
different ways as the Liberals put
forward yet another policy to try and
close the housing Supply Gap colleges
and universities will be eligible to use
the apartment construction loan program
to build uh housing on or off
campus that program will give
postsecondary institutions access to
over $15 billion worth of lowcost
government loans in a bid to build
student housing we're all in a bit of a
crisis right now so anything that can
help uh universities to increase the
number of lowcost units for students
will be good for the students good for
the universities and and good for the
communities and fixing the housing
crisis is Central to turning around the
Liberals political fortunes exclusive
polling for Global News done by ipsos
research list housing is the third most
important issue for Canadians only
behind cutting the cost of groceries and
inflation interest rates pocketbook
problems that are sticking to the Prime
Minister the difficulty for the liberal
party is it is 100% identified with
Justin Trudeau right now he is
definitely a drag on the Liberal Party
ticket that's given Pier POV in the
conservatives at 9-point lead in the
polls despite only presenting a handful
of economic policies well have has not
presented one damn Economic Policy since
it's been there regardless of how many
housing plans the Liberals put forward
experts have consistently said it will
take at least two years before their
impact is felt on the housing market
Donna well after when the next election
will be okay McKenzie in Ottawa thanks
RCMP and Manitoba say a man in British
Columbia has been charged with with the
murder of 24-year-old Crystal Saunders
who was killed 17 years ago
unfortunately Crystal was a vulnerable
person and someone took advantage of
that we now have that person in custody
42-year-old Kevin Charles Q was arrested
Saturday in Sur BC he will be taken back
to Winnipeg to face a second degree
murder charge Saunders body was found in
April of 2007 Northwest of
Winnipeg attacks and counterattacks
coming up the fears of those living
along the Lebanon Israel
border negotiators from qter Egypt and
Israel are said to be making progress on
a new deal to release more of the
hostages taken by Hamas on October 7th
Carter's prime minister says negotiators
plan to present a proposed framework to
Hamas leadership it involves a 45-day
pause in fighting more Aid to Gaza and
the release of 4,000 Palestinians from
Israeli detention in exchange Hamas
would release 35 to 40 Israeli hostages
possibly more in succeeding phases
Israeli news outlets report Israel is
open to the plan but nothing has been
agreed to and Hamas has reiterated
Israel must end its assault for more
hostages to be
released the UN relief Agency for
Palestinian refugees known as unra warns
the situation in Gaza is desperate as
more countries suspend funding after
allegations 12 of its staff were
involved in the October 7th Hamas attack
the UN agency warns if funding doesn't
resume soon its Aid work won't be able
to continue beyond February around 1
million Palestinians in Gaza displaced
by Israel's Siege rely on unra or
shelter US National Security
spokesperson warned today not to impune
the good work of a whole agency because
of the potential bad actions by a small
number of people in Israel thousands of
people including ministers from prime
minister benj netanyahu's government
attended a far-right conference last
night calling for Israel to resettle
Gaza and the occupied West
Bank that's Israel's national security
minister he and the Finance Minister
were there they reiterated calls for
Palestinians to be removed from Gaza
claiming without settlement there is no
security Netanyahu has said there are no
plans to permanently occupy Gaza but
insists that Israel will maintain
security control for an indefinite
period and Beyond the crisis in Gaza
fighting between Israeli forces and
Hezbollah militants is heating up along
the Israeli Lebanon border the Israeli
Defense Forces released footage of air
strikes on what it says are Hezbollah
military posts throughout Southern
Lebanon both sides have been trading
fire for months since the October 7th
attacks on Israel and that has left
border communities on edge Danielle
hamam Jin visited two Israeli kutzas
near the border with Lebanon
it's a brief Serene moment but at any
second rocket fire could tear through
this
rainbow just beyond a few hundred meters
away lies Southern Lebanon and this
kabut has been hit multiple times yes
yes where locals here say Hezbollah
Fighters backed by Iran are watching
closely they point to a Hilltop military
position perched right above on the
Lebanese side you cannot raise children
here when they go in the morning to the
kindergarten and you're afraid that a
rocket will hit the
kindergarten we're in kibuts
Malia where that kindergarten has been
turned into Army
Barracks this is one of the closest
Israeli communities to the Lebanese
border peacetime population 500 these
days a ghost town normal days you hear
sounds of kids running around
here um I hear sounds of
bombs this is Israel's response to an
earlier attack by
Hezbollah in fact this has been the
soundtrack of daily life in Northern
Israel since October
7th back and forth attacks and
counterattacks with a militant group
that has warned it is not afraid of war
with
Israel where forces have been
intensified fing drills preparing for
combat these communities are in direct
line of fire so close to the Lebanese
border that can hear the sound of
missiles and Rockets coming in before
the air eight Sirens can even
sound has bua is belief to be 10 times
stronger than Hamas and a full scale
attack could easily
overwhelm Israel's missile defense
system an Iron Dome will not take care
of 4,000 rockets on residential areas
it's a great weapon we're really proud
of it it's not a real Iron Dome we're
not in
Hollywood in kbut Sasa hardly anything
could have stopped the anti-tank missile
that hit the auditorium just a few weeks
ago Angelica Civ an Italian Israeli is a
theater teacher here this is the way to
my house I we can't we can't go in this
what do you
fear we fear that they see us because
all the time they see with the you know
with did and all the
time they can they can they can shoot a
greater fear is that what Hamas did on
October 7th in the South could be
replicated by Hezbollah in the
north Danielle hamam Jin global news on
the Israeli Lebanese
border turbulent times ahead why flare
Airlines has landed in hot water with
the
[Music]
CRA French Farmers call it a Siege of
Paris they have paralyzed Roots into the
French Capital blocking main arteries
with hundreds of tractors and mounds of
hay bales Farmers say they're being hit
by Falling incomes more environmental
regulations Rising red tape and
competition from Imports 15,000 police
officers have been mobilized to try to
control the protest the French
government says new measures to help
farmers will be announced on
Tuesday some turbulent times for flare
Airlines the Canada Revenue Agency has
obtained a court order to seize and sell
the budget carrier property court
documents show Flair owes $ 67.2 million
in unpaid taxes the money relates to
import duties on the 20 Boeing 737 Max
airplanes that make up its Fleet Flair
CEO Steven Jones says the company has a
deal with the CRA to pay off the money
owed and that the court order obtained
in November has no real impact on the
airlines
operations fighting a potential deadly
disease next British Colombia's
Innovative efforts to eradicate cervical
[Music]
cancer there's some Royal news tonight
both the Princess of Wales and King
Charles are back home after undergoing
medical procedures Kensington Palace
says Kate Middleton is recovering at
home after a nearly two-e Hospital stay
and is making good progress she had
abdominal surgery to treat treat an
undisclosed non-cancerous condition and
King Charles waved as he left the same
private London Hospital he spent three
nights being treated for an enlarged
prostate British Columbia is rolling out
a new way to screen for cervical cancer
instead of the invasive Pap test done in
a doctor's office at home test kits are
now available to screen for brains of
HPV the leading cause of cervical cancer
Heather uck West explains how it works
and why it could help eradicate the
disease Christina price is a cervical
cancer survivor she was diagnosed early
thanks to a test kit she administered at
home no I really I don't think I would
have caught it because I wasn't
scheduled for my regular Pap uh
Examination for about another year so I
don't know how fast it progresses or how
much it would have progressed Price's
early diagnosis came from participating
in BC's pilot study on the home cervical
cancer screening kits the study so
successful the tests are now available
to all patients as long as they live in
BC I actually think it's a really um
exciting uh project um major step
forward uh especially from the
standpoint of prevention of cervical
cancer Dr Gregory Nelson would like to
see the kits made available to patients
across the country the Pap test is
usually performed by a family doctor but
in many areas of Canada Family
Physicians are in short supply the pap
is also invasive and can be difficult
for those who have experienced trauma or
sexual abuse there are approximately
1300 cases of cervical cancer in Canada
per year and over 400 women die from
cervical
cancer making it one of the fastest
growing cancers in Canada but it doesn't
have to be with early detection cervical
cancer is easily treated and often cured
it's also preventable last week research
out of Scotland found zero cases of
cervical cancer among those who had been
fully vaccinated against HPV which is
you know a very uh dramatic finding I
think just further attesting that uh you
know that there's of really high
importance to patients receiving the HPV
vaccine it's why education a awareness
and access is so important so tools
available to eradicate this disease are
utilized by all Heather urex West Global
News
Calgary and that is global national for
this Monday I'm Donna FZ tonight's your
Canada is a snowflake in Edmonton just
50 days left until spring we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at Global national.com and
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]